what you believe about yourself is the
only thing that matters at the end of
the day no matter how much outside
affirmations you get or other people
telling you that you're amazing if you
don't believe in your heart that you are
amazing none of that will last like
you've ever gone to an event or you ever
made a video or created something or
you're hanging out with a friend and
they tell you how amazing you are and
that feels good but then it fades but
that stuff doesn't last you don't
hang a cheerleader for you every day
showing up in your bedroom saying hooray
go do this you're amazing right we don't
have that you have to be that for
yourself if you're constantly only
getting your value as a human being from
other people when they tell you that
you're amazing you're never gonna love
your life you're never gonna love
yourself it has to come from you has to
come from you telling yourself and you
believe in that you are amazing like for
me this is why I believe that lack of
belief is the world's number one problem
you know I can go and meet somebody and
fill them full of belief for a moment
but if they still don't believe in
themselves and they're going home back
to a life that they they had before
because they don't believe themselves
enough and so you have to design habits
and routines and systems and jewels to
slowly shift your belief in yourself
forward every single day need motivation
what's your top 10 with believe Nation
hey seven Carmichael and I make these
videos because running the business is
hard and waking up every day and getting
to work when you're all by yourself is
hard and the thing that saved me that
continues to inspire me motivate me give
me hope inspiration ideas is looking at
the stories of people who've done a lot
more than me and I learn strategies I
get motivation and it gets me to believe
in myself to go off and attack the day
and so I hope this video inspires you to
do the same as well so today let's learn
from me and my team's take on my top 10
rules of success
enjoy
rule number two is learn how to sell
whatever you want to sell show me the
process of you doing it so if you don't
have an email list yet you can even look
at who's following you on Instagram and
message people and say hey I I'm gonna
do a free coaching session for people
who wants 25 minutes of my time for free
to talk about coaching whatever issue
you have you're an entrepreneur whatever
confidence issue you're facing right now
I will Coach you for free but it's going
to be online okay those are two
different shows though the biz Dev show
is we're trying to build a relationship
with a potential client and get them on
the show to tell their story but then
inject a little bit of what you do 25 of
the show is about you and confidence
coaching helping them the second show is
just a straight up coaching show where
they know they're coming on
but they may not be in they may not be
an ideal client for you which is anybody
who needs okay okay
because I need I want to see that you're
a good coach because you can talk and
you can give me your Frameworks XYZ and
you can you can have all of your
material you can but that makes you a
good speaker
how do I know if you're a good coach
right like Ted Williams was a great
baseball player but he wasn't a great
coach so you could be a great speaker it
doesn't mean you're a good coach so how
do I know if you're a good coach I need
to see you coach
so you that's a that's a separate series
on the channel so now we're splitting it
up between the biz Dev show where we're
trying to get clients and a coaching
show where we're we don't care if
they're ideal clients are not coming on
We're just trying to show coaching and
help them of course and help them and
then if you have your website or you
build out your funnel that then becomes
content so when somebody lands on your
hey hire Frankie to be your coach I can
see examples of what you do and how you
coach people rule number three is focus
on your mission and you're just getting
started in all of this right yes the
opportunity here is
there's the big long-term opportunity of
you could help whether it's everybody
whether it's women whether female of
color or whatever that says a lot of
people in
even just North America who need that
yeah
the immediate opportunity is figuring
out okay how do we how do we replace our
salary
correct because the the women on the
train may not be able to afford you as a
coach right so this is where a lot of
people get stuck right at the beginning
I love these people and they're so good
like you didn't want to help and then
you get you get pulled into either
helping them for free or doing like
super discounted rate yeah and you feel
so fulfilling but it's like you are not
making money right so it's it's just an
order of sequencing so it's not
that you'll you're not able to help
those women in a deep way it's just not
now right because now is we need to
prioritize within our mission making
money
so that we can afford to quit our job
and then make more money so we can
afford to hire team to help us build our
brain so it like on purpose first yes
you have to learn how to monetize right
right number one is Mission purpose and
then somewhere in two to five has to be
making money if you're an entrepreneur
or you don't make money rule number four
is develop patience most entrepreneurs
aren't patient enough
months or year and really it's going to
take them four years five years before
they hit their Mark they don't have
enough patience they don't allow enough
time for momentum to build up and they
quit and they end up going back to a
crappy job that they hate and maybe
never ever take a shot and get an
entrepreneurship because they feel it's
not for them or really they missed out
you missed out on your destiny you
missed on creating something amazing
because you just didn't have enough
patience now
I believe in patients in the macro I
believe in patience and knowing it's
going to take a long time I also think
in patients can serve you greatly but
that's in the micro that's in the daily
the impatience of did I do my best today
did I do my best today can I do better
can I drive more can I drive harder and
knowing that even if I give my best
every single day it's still going to
take time
it's still gonna take a number of years
for something to happen I want it to
happen as soon as possible I'm going to
drive and be impatient as crazy to get
it going but I know it's going to take
time too it's embracing both that's when
you start to win I look at my it's my
YouTube my Instagram my social media
strategy YouTube
7 000 subscribers four years ago 1.2
million subscribers now four years by
making videos every day every day and
I'm impatient as anything because I want
it to be amazing I want to make every
video better than the last and looking
for all the hacks and SEO and thumbnail
strategies and title strategies and all
of the stuff that we're supposed to do
right I'm on top of it and I know that
it's going to take me four years to get
there I know it's going to take me a
while to get to my next two million five
million 10 million I look at Instagram
follow me on my Instagram Journey I'm
starting from nothing you can see how to
build it up from zero I had eight
thousand followers many of you already
have more followers than I do on
Instagram but I'm gonna win I'm gonna
pass people I'm gonna get mine because
I'm gonna make daily consistent content
three to four times a day for four years
I'm gonna be impatient as anything and
that the post today has to be amazing
has to be something that I want to show
my grandkids right that's the intent
every time I create anything I want my
grandkids to watch this video I want my
grandkids to watch the next Instagram
thing that I put up it's the best that I
can come up with in the moment and I
know it's going to take me four years
maybe three years maybe two years but
it's not gonna take me two months
I realize it's gonna take working hard
and working smart together always
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is connect with
your community how you are like
connecting with your followers on a
level that is adding value to them
but is allowing them to continue to
consume your content one you have to
love it
um like I love
connecting with the community
okay so there's a lot of people who who
don't love it and you don't have to do
it right so I remember was in New York I
was meeting a really big name author you
know New York Times for sale Etc and
I was in town to say hey let's go grab
breakfast so we grab breakfast together
and he said well what are you doing for
the rest of the day it's like I'm gonna
have lunch with another fan who said he
like became a millionaire after watching
my content and then we're gonna do an
afternoon meet up at a Starbucks with
you know my fans in New York and we're
just gonna chill at a Starbucks and ask
questions I don't care about seeing New
York I just care about meeting the
people and he said that sounds
exhausting like oh what are you gonna do
it's like I'm gonna go back to my room
and write and he's had tons of success
as a writer right so it's not that one
way is better than the other it's just
that I I love doing it
and so it's tapping into like if that's
where you get your energy from of the
audience that you have and people
listening to you watching you Etc then
that's where the thing needs to be
birthed not from uh this is a good
strategy so I guess I should do it right
so inside of that
I do things like that where I do meetups
in cities when I travel even here
inviting you back it's like you message
me it's like hey what are you doing on
Tuesday you want to come by and do
something you know for Content too and
every day I'll do Instagram questions if
you see my stories I always put a
question and then at the end of the
night my evening routine no matter how
tired I am I'm still like responding to
questions I'll do like 10 questions and
you'll responding yourself yeah it's me
like when I'm helping people I try to do
it with the scalability to it as well
okay so
you know the people who are here today
that I'm helping or helping but it's
also content so other people can learn
from it hopefully in in your story right
when I'm doing Instagram q a
it's on my story so people can leave a
question I'll answer it for everybody
okay right
um I still do a lot of one-on-ones in
the DMS as well but that there's just
not enough time in the day to hit
everyone even the questions that come in
every day I don't have time yeah to do
everybody but it's more of a heart thing
where it's like I need that as part of
my nightly routine to stay connected to
the work
because otherwise it becomes why am I
doing this stuff you know the numbers
start to blur or not mean much right you
know you had a million or two million or
whatever it's like okay
I don't know what that means but
somebody's saying your video changed my
life you saying you know I watched your
videos for eight years every day to
learn from somebody new
that that's why I do what I do I need to
feel connected to who I'm
serving or helping
and in doing that then it makes me want
to show up more because if you're just
making videos in your office or you're
just recording the song in the studio
and you can't connect to like who it's
going to actually help at least for me
it's not as powerful rule number six is
build a team stop trying to do this
alone
if you've got a big idea inside you you
can't do this alone you need people
around you to help you to encourage you
to support you to cover your weaknesses
to help you actually go off and
accomplish that big dream of yours this
is one of the biggest things that I
think holds people back holds
entrepreneurs back
is you're probably decently good at the
thing that you want to do
you know you've had some experience or
you've gone and learned and figured it
out and you still to get better as you
keep practicing and keep going and doing
more and maybe at some point you even
did try to hire somebody maybe at some
point you did try to bring somebody on
and it didn't work out
didn't work out
and here's where everybody makes the
mistake you Retreat and go back to say
you know what it was just a lot faster
when I did it myself does that happen
has that happened to you ever been there
you hired somebody you thought I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna hire somebody you do
it it doesn't work out
and then you go back to say I'm just
going to do this all myself no no no no
no no that is not the answer
that is not the answer that's like if
you go on one date and it doesn't work
out now you're never going to go on
another date again you're never gonna be
married
right that doesn't make sense
that doesn't make sense you're living in
fear as opposed to actually trying to
build the things that you're capable of
building
here's what happens
when you first hire somebody you know
what you're doing
right it's like when you first did
anything you don't know what you're
doing
so why do you expect to be great at
picking the right person and then
treating them well then managing them
well you don't know what you're doing
there's a guy in my Movie Makers who
joined my Discord as well
and he was talking about how he had
hired his second video editor and it
didn't work out
and he had to let the person go so he's
hired two video editors both of them
couldn't get his style
and he had to let them go and he's going
back to editing everything himself now
as a short-term solution great like
stuff has to get up videos have to be
edited get them out
but don't stop searching
just because you had two failed hires
right like if you tomorrow are editing
videos awesome but if you next year are
still editing your videos not awesome
nope not awesome not anymore right this
is how we start to raise our standards
and so the first two people that you
hired weren't good fits great keep
searching keep looking
your perfect fit is out there and as you
go through some people and go through
the process you'll get better at
actually finding the right person
you know you'll get better at it don't
judge yourself that say well I suck at
this I can't hire I'm never going to
find the person it's just faster to do
it myself right there's that old
expression you can go fast by yourself
but you go far with a team
you have to build a team rule number
seven is practice self-love when you
look at yourself in the mirror what do
you say when you think about yourself
what do you say a lot of a lot of the
stuff that we say about ourselves we
wouldn't we wouldn't say to our worst
enemies it's rough I actually think it's
great to be your own worst critic
I think it's great I think honestly I
think for a lot of people
um we're not hard enough on ourselves
let me let me stick with me for a minute
we're not hard enough on ourselves
because in order to get to where you
want to go you actually need to push
yourself more the problem is why we
can't do it is
we don't love ourselves enough we're not
our biggest cheerleader enough you have
to balance those two things we're very
hard on ourselves but because there's no
self-love we're not cheering ourselves
on enough we're not our biggest
cheerleader
you can't handle it most people are
already at the breaking point you know
like I'm sitting here in a parking lot
these you know those I guess it's kind
of blurry you can't really see them but
people hate their lives
they're barely hanging on most people
are barely hanging on
we're barely hanging on to what we're
doing we we can post all these great
things on Instagram or wherever and make
it look like we're enjoying our life but
most people are barely hanging on the
people who are judging you for your life
and telling you that you suck hate their
own lives they are barely hanging on so
how do we get through it well yes we can
be harder on ourselves but we need to
balance that with more self-love
you have to remind yourself of why
you're great what you're proud of what
you're grateful for
and it has to be consistent otherwise
you'll never get to where you want to go
and when you love yourself more that
actually allows you to be harder on
yourself
when you love yourself when you actually
feel it you can push yourself harder
you can you can be more
um
demanding of yourself
because it's not going to push you over
the edge because you're not tying your
self-worth
to you accomplishing that thing and when
you don't accomplish it you feel like a
loser
it's starting from a place of I'm
amazing
that allows you to be way harder on
yourself rule number eight is find your
ideal clients you've got your Biz Dev
show and the point of business that show
is to bring ideal clients on if you
don't think they're an ideal client or
they could refer ideal clients to you
then they're not on the show I get the
life open on this morning was to
uh pick entrepreneurs shoes
entrepreneurs that come on to
entrepreneurial ship show and in our
mind uh well in my mind entrepreneurs
will probably watch it because I'm
talking to an entrepreneur entrepreneur
so yeah I I'm I really my mind has
really shifted yeah but they're coming
on and just listening to somebody else's
story
that doesn't why would I then hire you I
don't know you're just Larry King asking
questions you're a great question asker
right okay well I'm not hiring you for
that
so unless your goal is to be an emcee or
the whole shows or something else then
then that's a different model right but
it's like I'm a coach and I want to sell
more coaching Services then that that's
a better model so you're bringing people
if they don't if they're either not an
ideal client meaning they have a
business and they can afford your
services like it was a brand new startup
and they're dead broke
it's not an ideal client because they
can't afford you
so ideal clients or referral Partners
lawyers accountants those kinds of
people who deal with entrepreneurs all
day long like if you have the right
lawyer on and they love you they could
be referring everyone rule number nine
is choose positivity you can choose at
any moment
positivity you
use at any moment gratitude you can
choose at any moment service you can
choose to change your mindset in in an
instant if you wanted to the challenge
is we're so living in our subconscious
mode that we don't we don't catch it
soon enough we don't think the action
that we're proud of and then we regret
it you know we regret it later on this
morning I woke up really early I'm very
tired I woke up at 3 45 a.m for some
reason don't know why uh look at my look
at my watch like 3 45 a.m what oh man
okay try to go back to sleep toss turn
for about an hour and then I got up like
okay you know it's 12 45 it's almost
five you know let's let's get up and I
got to work and started doing things and
then the crash hit me
the crash hit me just not enough sleep
and everything inside me wanted to shut
down you know I wanted to just take the
complete break not do my walk in the
morning not not take the dogs out while
the dogs have to go out but not do my
routine not do any of my usual stuff not
record videos today's a Tuesday we're
going to record it's video recording day
and it's in these moments those trying
times that you have to decide who you
want to be you have to decide if you
want to choose to be positive choose to
live in gratitude choose to live in
productivity choose live in service or
not what would the future you think of
your actions right now
and I think 95 of the time the answer is
to push a little harder move the brake
line forward right where where you would
normally take a break move that forward
just a little bit move the brake line
forward a touch
and five percent of the time you have to
be more gentle on yourself
when my family dog passed away when I
broke my neck when you know all sorts of
things have happened to me just like
they've happened to you sometimes the
answer is to give yourself a little more
grace
to recognize how far you've come
everything that you've done with the
limited amount of resources and time
that you have
but I think if we default to that then
we default to stay in stock and staying
small because life is going to throw so
many different challenges at you
so I think 95 of the time that's the
five percent right five percent of time
you give yourself more grace you let
yourself off the hook you take the day
off you do whatever you need especially
if you're struggling with grief
if you're struggling with grief I think
you just have to work your way through
it you have to give yourself a lot of
Grace and a lot of time and it will get
better and and just please don't go
through it alone
but almost everything else
usually the answer is to keep going
because it'll make you more proud
because you're teaching yourself that
you stand up to obstacles then you
overcome item number 10 the last time
before some very special bonus Clips is
open your heart to people do you have
any tips for creators that are starting
out on the platform and are looking to
build their audience organically oh yeah
no no I'm answering the question okay
the thing is
you need to open your heart to people
so I asked you a hard question and you
shut it down and move back ahead yeah
right because you said I'm honest I want
to document my self-love Journey that's
why I'm doing my house and my workout
you said I want to document myself love
Journey should I ask you a word you
struggle with self-love that's a that's
a heart opening opportunity
and then you went to
well I've I've grown I've fixed a lot
and I've I'm much more and I don't
really struggle with that anymore okay
cool and maybe you don't awesome but
where do you struggle
because if you're telling the stories
about 17 hour days and photo shoots and
it's like the Glam life cool but it's
not really relatable
so what are you struggling with what's
the negative voice in your mind because
you're you're you're you're gonna you're
part Fierce badass gonna show up and
crush and want to change the world right
that's in you and then you're also
insecure and self-doubt and like is this
even worth it and when is it going to
happen for me and like all of those
emotions too and all of us are
yeah but that's the heart stuff that if
you can figure out how to dive into that
stuff on a video people will then start
to love you and feel connected to you
and you're still badass Fierce chasing
down your goals
they're showing all
if you're writing songs with your head
and not your heart's not going to win
if you go into the studio think okay
what is a hit song going to be and let
me just copy whoever and this is a track
versus no I have something to say this
is what's on my heart like those will be
the better songs
and so if you already do that in your
art now it's bringing that to just a new
form of Art
and what you want is people to actually
join you the language you use is great
I'm on my journey of self-love and if
you want to swap that up for something
else cool but you take people on the
journey then they want to join with you
on the journey but you have to let them
in
not just kind of watching from the
outside
most people don't get what they want
because you don't follow through enough
just don't follow through it's based out
of insecurity you start and stop start
and stop you're afraid of hurting
people's feelings you're afraid of what
they're gonna say about you you're
afraid they're gonna judge you and
we're afraid of having that L on our
personal resume so we we stop we stop
and try to do something else where we're
seeing more immediate results but if
it's your goal if it's your dream you
have to follow through one of my
favorite stores is with Brendan Bouchard
and I went to speak at his event in
Phoenix and I I knew of him but I didn't
know him at the time it was his business
partner that had me come out to his
event
and hired me to speak there and that's
where I met Brendan for the first time
and he asked me hey what are you working
on what can I help you know what's next
for you and I said I won't work on my
book and he said I'd love to uh I'd love
to help I'd love to give you some
feedback on your book like I am
definitely down for that
let's connect and uh he's he asked me
what my phone number was and at the time
I didn't have a phone I didn't use a
phone number and I said how about email
and he said oh I'm not really good on
email but if that's the only way then
let's do email so we exchanged emails
and uh I didn't I didn't hear from him
so I I followed up and I said hey
Brendan thank you you know great event
um love to talk about
the book like you suggested and didn't
hear back and followed up a couple weeks
later and didn't hear back and followed
up a couple weeks later and then uh he
said oh man thank you uh I'm super
swamped right now but uh let Let's
either do
come out to my place and we'll do a jam
session or I've got this event coming up
maybe you can come be there I said yeah
I'm down for either which one you want
to do and didn't hear back and then
wrote a couple more messages and didn't
hear back and here's what's really
important
in my head
every time I sent another email I I was
questioning myself I was judging myself
like oh I don't want to bother him
uh maybe maybe I'm I'm being too
overwhelming maybe maybe he doesn't
actually want me to come out maybe I'm
offending him maybe you know I'm not
respecting him maybe I'm asking for too
much you know that's that's the thought
in my head before every email where in
reality
Mr busy guy he had a lot of stuff going
on he had a launch that was happening
that I wasn't even aware of uh that he
was planning behind the scenes and so he
is he was you know not crazy stressed
out but he just has a lot on his plate
that he's dealing with and it's hard to
tell ourselves that it's easier to
default to the insecurity of maybe
you're bothering maybe you're asking too
much maybe you're not worthy maybe you
should move on the event that he talked
about me coming to was coming up
and I still hadn't heard back whether
whether he wanted me there or not or you
know my book launch was coming up too
and I thought
I'm gonna send one more email
just one more email that's it I'm gonna
send one more email and hopefully
something happens if not then I'm done
and um hopefully you know he doesn't
think I'm a loser or whatever
and he he wrote back an email and like
hey sorry man again I'm not super great
on email just been swamped planning all
these things uh yeah come on out come
out to the event speak at the event too
and that was his big event that was you
know 30 to 50 000 a year Mastermind to
be a part of that then I spoke on stage
and then at the event after I spoke
I met with him and Dean graziosi
backstage for an hour over lunch and
planned my entire book strategy that
then led to me getting invited to go to
Brendan's house uh a couple days later
and hang with him and Dean and Tom bilio
and Lewis Howes and Jay Shetty and
Russell Brunson in all sorts of amazing
humans who built giant businesses all of
that happened
because I sent that one more email
because I followed up and I followed up
and I followed up and I followed up and
it wasn't that he hated me or that he
thought I sucked or that I was being
overwhelming or whatever that that I
kept following up just had the
persistence there's a lot of
opportunities there in front of you
right now
that
just are not happening because there's
not enough follow-up there's not enough
persistence today we are talking about
finding sponsors a couple ideas here the
first one is be the authority in your
industry and this is how I started
getting my first sponsors is that people
knew me as being the entrepreneur guy
first off just in my city like I'm the
entrepreneur guy in Toronto and for this
to happen it has to be really Niche how
do I Niche down so that people find me
because if you're just talking about
motivation you're up against Tony
Robbins and Mel Robbins and Eric Thomas
and Evan Carmichael and all these big
channels so why would a giant company
want to work with you at least why would
they come to you they wouldn't be your
first choice to come to you so I was
thinking about how can I be the go-to in
my specific industry and one of the
biggest things that I found too for
helping people get more business from
YouTube is going more Niche like who
specifically do you help and making
content directly geared towards them
this is something that you and I have
been working on and helping some of his
clients he's helped some clients get
five six figure deals from their YouTube
channels and they have a hundred
subscribers what
problem is freaking out yeah because the
videos are specific right so who do you
ideally want to be helping and making
content directly towards them and so a
lot of a lot of times the problem is our
content is too General it's too broad
yeah and you're going up against big
people and so you won't be the one that
they find but some of the stuff that
that he puts up is is relatively obscure
a niche like how can a dentist uh invest
in life insurance
is it pretty specific Niche thing
and the goal isn't to have a million
views on that video but anybody who's
watching that video is going to be an
ideal target market for you
and so if if I'm a dentist and I'm
trying to invest in life insurance and I
find that video there aren't probably
too many videos there's videos talking
about how dentists can grow a business
or entrepreneurs and grow business this
video is talking about life insurance
but not that combination and in that
combination we start to get people
who are our ideal clients
so it's yes building up I love that
you're building the giant channels what
I love doing but I also want you to make
money along the way and if you have any
kind of client service business or
products that you want to sell making it
specific knowing that we're not trying
to get a million subscribers yet on
these videos but it can start to pay us
it also attracts the attention of
potential sponsors
so the the more Niche you can get
especially when the channel is small the
more Niche you can get the more people
will find you who care about that Niche
was it hard for you to dig inside and
say I'm going to work on Evan I love
taking on new things like you have a
different modality that you want to no
nobody's models ever quite fit me so
it's cool but I'm happy to try on the
next model you guys you have your eight
step personality test cool I'm uh
electrifier awesome
you know like it never quite fits but
all of them are good
good pass I'm not locked into one
modality like it's got to be the Colby
score it's got to be the Myers-Briggs
there's got to be the whatever but they
all teach you a little bit about
yourself even even down to
I just have my DNA tested and from the
DNA test they show you hey based on your
genes you're more susceptible to these
kinds of foods and this kind of activity
and all this kind of stuff like okay
those are like they're averages so it's
it's a good starting point
I love trying stuff I love trying stuff
for me to learn and also to to
demonstrate to other people that go try
stuff you need to create an environment
of Excellence most people's environments
are not excellent the people around you
the videos that you watch the things
that are on your wall the voices that
are in your head you have these moments
that are bold that are courageous that
make you feel Unstoppable and you can do
anything and then you fall back down
because the environment is the thing
that's keeping you small it takes a
giant effort to overcome your
environment you definitely can it's
definitely possible tons of people are
doing it but it takes that giant effort
to say I don't want to stay stuck here
most people stay stuck most people make
minimal improvements in their life year
over year and if you don't want to stay
where you are right now fast forward to
one year from today you don't want to
stay stuck you want to be in a different
place could actually be physically
moving but a different place in terms of
your finances in terms of your purpose
like today this is not acceptable
anymore I accept that this is where I am
right now but where I end up is not
going to be the same spot as where I am
right now the biggest shift that will
help you get from where you are now to
where you want to be is creating that
environment of Excellence what's the
fastest way to learn a language what's
the fastest way to learn Japanese well
it's to go to Japan sure you can read
some books and and you can hire a tutor
and that the more intense it becomes the
more you're actually living it the
faster you're going to pick it up
so if you want to develop the mindset of
the high achiever if you want to become
that person the people that you look up
to the the whoever of the world like I
want to be the next whoever perfect that
person the more you hang around with
them the more it's going to rub off on
you how they think because how they
think how they act how they behave how
they see the world is very different
than how you see it right now and how
the people around you definitely see the
world right now
so how do you do it how do you start to
become it well
I look at what I'm doing
and this was one of my biggest
challenges when I was getting started
and honestly still in like I think the
biggest problem in the world is a lack
of belief
I'm trying to solve the world's biggest
problem people don't believe in
themselves enough I don't you don't
Oprah doesn't people don't believe in
themselves enough for the next level so
how do you start to believe in yourself
more the thing that helped me the most
was to have these successful people
around me constantly
and so I want to share a few tactics
that I think can really help you that
has really helped me as being the shy
introverted kid who never wanted to be
in front of a camera and was making 300
bucks a month and quit on my business
partner and thought life was over right
to now hear and it's taken me 20 years
to get here so hopefully we can shorten
that path for you if you actually follow
some of the advice in this video
so step number one how do we create that
environment of Excellence
what you feed into your brain really
really really matters
so figure out how you love to learn for
me it's videos I like to see things I
need to be visual if that's you then you
need to have a way to have those videos
coming into your life every day it can
be part of your morning routine that's
why I make this channel part of your
morning routine subscribe to the channel
every morning every weekday we got a new
video out there for you to give you the
shot of Express that'll help you but if
it's not my channel it's some other
channel one of my other channels
subscribe to the channels that make you
feel bold powerful Unstoppable give you
hope give you belief in yourself
and then watch that video every day or
listen to that podcast every day or read
that book every day the trick is it
can't be the same book or the the one
video because that one video on repeat
is gonna lose its Effectiveness right
you know what you watch a video gets you
all fired up and then you watch again
the next day and it's not as like oh
what happened I don't feel as good and
you watch it the next day and the
feeling's gone so you can't just read
the same book over and over watch the
same video over and over and over again
the key is to find a consistent source
so if you love this channel you love
this video I'm making other videos just
like this
that you can subscribe to if you'd like
an author go find their other books or
go find the people that Inspire them so
that you can read something every day if
you'd like a podcast go find other
podcasts like them so you have something
every day so you you are
manipulating what comes in your head
with intention now
with intention so you're not just
scrolling through things like I am going
to watch one of these videos every day
to slowly shift myself forward because
it'll happen if you love Elon Musk and
you watch Elon Musk every day what will
happen is slowly day by day you will
start to think like Elon Musk it will
happen he will pull you forward you will
start to see the big difference in how
he thinks versus how the people around
you think versus how you think right now
and he will give you more courage and
more boldness and more a sense of hope
and purpose that you can do it too
you'll start to think more like him how
to get over someone that you love after
breakup when it still hurts so whether
it's a breakup in uh in a personal
relationship in a business relationship
you can always think about what you what
you would have done what you should have
done what you could have done looking
backwards but it very rarely serves you
the easiest way to move past is to start
to get excited about the future
when you are excited about your future
you spend zero time thinking about all
the things that you did wrong going
backwards right you did the best you
could with what you had forgive yourself
if you had to do it all over again you
would probably play a little bit
different now because you're smarter
you're wiser you have more experience
but you can't go back in time and and
sitting wishing that you could and all
the mistakes that you would have fixed
doesn't serve you so the key is to start
getting excited about the future
get excited about the future what are
you building what are you craving what
are you moving towards not where you
have come from and where you struggled
and sucked so if it's a business
opportunity get excited about the new
business you're going to make if it's a
relationship
get excited about the next relationship
you're going to have right get on the
get on the different dating apps and see
who's out there see who's on the market
for you right now and get excited like
allow yourself to dream again and to
wish again and to Hope again because
that thing that you came from was not
the one for you anyway you're trying to
move through some past mistakes
you give yourself credit for doing the
best you could with what you had and
then we start getting excited about the
future that is still ahead most of the
things that I guess other people might
see is failure honestly it's failure
what's a failure I really didn't do well
like I choked on a hair while I was
talking and I guess a lot of the things
that most people would see is failure I
don't see as failure I don't even see
this feedback it just was and now we're
moving on I Don't Look Backwards right
it's like okay whatever that's done cool
let's go forward oh you have feedback
for me cool I filmed without the
microphone was out of failure I see it
as a win I don't think I take big enough
risk to ever have a real failure like if
I mortgaged my house to make this day
like insane and Danny says Hey to make
this thing fly we need Val kilm or
riding an elephant like crashing through
the front door and then that had to work
or I lost my house that's a failure to
me so everything else is all manageable
I think it's a strength and a weakness
it limits how much upside I have but
this also means a zero downside it's for
imposter syndrome honestly
um there's two things that I'll do one
is remember who you're focused on
serving right we're so worried about
trying to be someone that we're not and
who might judge us and who might comment
on your video or whatever it was
something nasty but focus on who you're
serving who you are serving like
somebody needs your message today you've
got a message you've been through
something you have advice to share
somebody needs that and focus on who
that person is and it may not be a
million people it may just be eight
people who watch your video but for one
person that might be a life like your
message might be the life-changing
message that they need today and so
focus on that when you're out there
creating and two the other thing I find
helpful is imagine you're talking to
younger you
so
when we get stuck in imposter syndrome
we think of oh if you look at Angela
who's hosting her own show like well but
I'm not Larry King or I'm not Oprah or
I'm not whoever and we let that be the
reason why we don't start
whereas think about who you used to be
so for me the most painful point in my
life was 19 when I quit on my business
partner and so I go back to think can I
help 19 year old Evan
if I was gonna sit on a park bench and
talk to 19 year 11 would I have
something that I could say and yeah of
course of course I could help I may not
believe I can help a million people but
I believe I can help younger me and same
thing for you you may not feel like you
can help tons of people you have
imposter syndrome about that but if you
think back to who you used to be think
about who you were five years ago you
from five years ago would listen to you
today and they may not listen to Evan
Carmichael or Oprah or whoever but
they'll listen to you
and so
if you you can have a message for
younger you well there's millions of
people who currently are younger you and
they're struggling
and they need you
and just I don't know just the way that
that is framed
for me gets me out of my way
and forces me to get into action mode
they're both an angle of service you
know I'm always going to lean on service
one is you're thinking about the people
who you can help and two as you think
back to younger you and recognize that
you could help younger you and there are
millions of people right now who are
younger you
and they need your help
so it's time to go through you don't
know what the final product is you're
trying to get because if it's an
internal fulfillment if it's a feeling
you can't quantify that and if you can't
quantify it you can't reverse engineer
it so my mind is wired numbers but like
my heart is going more towards the the
helping and serving but you can't map
that out to break down steps so it's
like an it's like a it's like a
dichotomy I hear you
but you kind of can in that
the feeling of fulfillment that you're
chasing
how many times when you've been in a
room
with a lot of people or just with one
person that you've helped do you leave
feeling
more fulfilled
often so that's how you quantify it
put you in a room with somebody who
needs help
and you'll eighty percent of the time
come out with more fulfillment that's
what I said like that's the missing
piece because you're not feeling the
connection you're all push push push and
no hugs like you need the feeling
because okay I had a thousand Instagram
followers now two thousand or whatever
it is like it doesn't mean enough
because it's a momentary you cross that
number but there's no heart
the heart is when you're talking and
you're actually very good at you say I'm
all you're not just all mine you're
great at connecting to people and
helping them
you do it naturally
more than anybody on my whole tour
we did in every city I went across
America you were like the most the only
guy who didn't talk about himself and
like used his time to help the other
people
so you're naturally great at it you're
just not putting yourself in the
position to do it
and so you can XO quantify it if you
were to twice a week do something with
somebody else who needs help
80 of the time you're going to come out
feeling more fulfilled like I'm I'm
Kick-Ass at what I do I'm so happy that
I had that conversation with that person
because you're actually good at it and
it's like if you sucked at it then it
might be 25 but you're actually really
good at it so 80 90 of the time you're
going to come out feeling more fulfilled
which then gives you the courage and the
motivation to then stay consistent
because you're all push but there's no
consistency when you can match the push
in the hug then you'll stay consistent
because you're you feel that it's
fulfilling
if you're not fulfilled
you won't stay consistent it's just
little thing to chase like I'm going to
start and stop in certain stock right if
you actually felt fulfilled in the work
like this is Meaningful this was really
cool I want to do it again you'll stay
more consistent on all the work
s to write things down I'm the kind
two in the morning or or you know three
at night or whatever it is when I have
an idea I want to write it down I feel
like unless I can get it out of my head
and now I tend to just send myself an
email right in Evernote until I get it
out of my head
I I'm I'm unsettled I feel like I'm
gonna forget the idea and it's something
that I've wrestled with this message of
you know maybe I'm just not gonna write
anything down
and the best ideas that I have will just
continue to come back and come back and
come back and those are the ones that I
should run with and if I look at how
many times I actually look over that
Evernote file it's pretty slim
and I feel like I kind of do it anyway
where the best ideas come back to me
over and over again and that's what I
run with but I haven't fully embraced it
maybe it's out of fear of losing a great
idea and every now and then when I look
through the notes something does come
back and I end up running with it and I
fear that I may have forgot it if I
didn't write it down and I could have
missed a big chunk of a big project I'm
working on but maybe that's an
irrational fear I don't know this is
something that I want to play with more
I do know that when I was thinking about
my one word of believe that's been the
foundation for this Channel and a lot of
the you know work that I do when I first
thought about it I felt like it was too
big I felt like it wasn't the right one
for me I felt like uh I felt like it was
hard to live up to and the more I slept
on it the more time went on the more you
know I experimented with it the more it
felt right and every passing day
that big idea just stuck with me more
and more and more until I embraced it
fully and it became the basis of this
Channel and and my website and all the
work that I do
so I think there's something there I
feel like I don't do a good enough job
on it and I wonder if it might be worth
an experiment for a week
to not write anything down
and just trusted the Big Ideas will stay
there
that's an interesting one
I'm gonna think on that I'm not going to
write it down
I'm going to think on that I'm
passionate about helping I want people
to learn man and I don't think we're
getting it in schools I don't think
you're getting entrepreneurship
knowledge in textbooks and I'm
passionate about trying to help the
entrepreneurs who have the information
to get it out there so I've connected
with pretty much everybody I guess in
the thought leadership Entrepreneur
Space and I just help them with their
channels and and good stuff happens you
know I mean even looking at this I don't
know how we got initially connected but
we hopped on a call maybe a month or two
ago to look at your YouTube channel and
then you said hey man come on my show
like I'm down you know good things
happen when you give so if you're a
business owner you're an expert at
something your job is to teach people to
think like you think
and what I love you look at my LED or
you look at yourself you guys think
differently right the way you approach
things you're not your typical
boardroom CEO professional corporate guy
right and so
the questions that you ask are not the
normal ones the way you see the world is
not what other people see and so that's
that's your job as a as an expert as a
business leader to share the way that
you see the world so others can see the
world the same way our ideas are
[Music]
I've got Big Ideas you want to change
the world right and that's great and
it's great like dream dream big and okay
it's it's then this gets so easy to get
lost in our Big Dreams and it's like
well what do I what do I do we're
building the ladder we're creating the
bridge we're getting in the boat and
we're rolling like this is the first
step and and what's great is you already
have a product service that you can sell
I don't know what I'm gonna sell I don't
know who I can help I don't know what my
skills are like you've already figured
that out which is great
so now we just need to figure out okay
uh how many clients you need to need to
get so that you can get that team those
two people and then you'll feel so
you'll have so much more momentum
just imagine an EA or a VA taking 20 30
hours a week of warp off your plate what
does that free up for you to do
yeah
yeah right a lot like maybe maybe you
can already afford to hire that person
now and if it's not 20 hours a week
maybe it's five hours a week or 10 hours
a week right
um yes that's how you get the scale up
yeah but it's these steps
local that's it
because a lot of people hear that what
you say but I don't want to
dream so small
no I'm not asking a dream small like
dream big dream bigger
which is building the plan to actually
get there because the thing that's
missing between where and not just you
where like most people are and where
they want to be is they don't have the
team and the resources to do it so let's
go get you some more resources so you
can get the team to go off and build
your even bigger Mission the fastest way
to change your habits is to change your
environment you ever notice how when
you're in a different environment maybe
you go on vacation maybe you go to an
event or seminar
you start doing different things you are
still you and you do some of the things
that you used to do but all of a sudden
you're doing new things that become a
part of your regular routine you ever
been away for a couple weeks and
discover that you built up some new
habits and maybe some are healthy maybe
some are unhealthy but if you've ever
been away and you notice that you've
picked up some new habits why well
because the environment demanded it
because everybody else was doing it
because it was so easy natural
comfortable to do that that that's why
you do it too and so if you want to be
able to switch your habits quickly you
change your environments now you may not
always be able to go on vacation or go
to events or seminars or those those are
options but it starts with you figuring
out well what are
the habits that you want to develop who
are the people that you want to be
around and when you are around those
people you will start to think
differently which will lead to you
behaving differently when you see other
people doing it you're going to want to
do it more when it's in your environment
more you're going to want to do it more
too to change your life you have to be
willing to change your actions
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over and over again
and expecting a different result
if you want to change your life you want
to be in a different spot you have to be
doing different things now if you love
your life great don't change anything or
you love pieces of your life don't
change anything about those pieces but
if you are not happy with where you are
at you must be able be willing to do
different things otherwise you will stay
stuck forever I was doing an Instagram
live yesterday with a young entrepreneur
he wants to be a speaker and he wants to
share his message and he's constantly
facing
self-doubt and fear and insecurity and
nobody's watching the stories and he's
not good enough and who am I to share a
message in inner IG live one of the
things he said was
well I'm not I'm not comfortable doing
that we're talking about making making
content some days he's on top of the
world and feels great and other days if
he's not and he doesn't feel comfortable
to get in front of the camera
and he started going off and telling me
a story stop right there
when you say I'm not comfortable doing
that
we have to identify that as a trigger to
go
saying I'm not comfortable doing that
now if it's against your values I get it
right you're not comfortable you know
I'm at Costco right now Nina's going
shopping in there I'm not comfortable
robbing Costco perfect okay that's
outside my value system that's totally
different most of the things that you're
not comfortable doing
are failing in front of other people
at the end of the day it's what it is
you're afraid of being judged and so
we're not comfortable doing that thing
you'll you'll fail if nobody else sees
it if it's just you but you don't want
to fail in front of other people and
that can no longer be a good enough
reason because if you only do think
about this if you only do what's
comfortable
you stay in your comfort zone
if you only do what's comfortable
and therefore you hate your life
because if all you did was wake up and
do what's in your comfort zone do what
is known do what is comfortable do what
do what you've always done you're gonna
hate your life and this becomes the
curse of a lot of entrepreneurs is you
know you're capable of more you know you
want to do more you know you have more
in your heart to go up and serve you you
want that you can you can see it you can
touch it you can taste it you can
visualize it's like I want to be there I
want to do that right has that happened
to you can that relate to you
you know you want more but you're afraid
to go off and do it and and you fall
back down to comfort at least
consistently you might have these
moments of greatness and boldness and
willingness to go do something but we
fall back down to comfort
and if you stay in comfort you will
never accomplish your great goals
because everything you want out of life
is on the other side of your comfort
zone
everything you want out of life
all your big goals your Big Dreams your
big Ambitions your mission the life that
you want the life that you want is on
the other side of your comfort zone
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there we have 52 people on the team now
if you ask me how many people on my team
I'd say I don't know 10. and like really
who and then I look at the list like oh
yeah because I'm not in all the stuff
and and I just forget